[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon if you'd like to help
support my channel and get early access
to every video consider becoming a
patron at patreon.com second thought
once upon a time the human race had a
dream a vision of the future where we
had evolved beyond our petty military
conflicts where every human was
guaranteed equal rights where we had
time to spend with friends and family to
pursue hobbies and trades and to do
meaningful work that we enjoyed not
because we had to but because tedious
unpleasant labor had been handed off to
automated systems leaving humans the
time to just live to really experience
what life is all about as we approach
the year 2022 i think it's safe to say
that vision is no closer today than it
was a hundred years ago in fact the
consensus seems to have shifted away
from this utopian vision of the future
and towards something much less pleasant
in this episode we're going to attempt
to analyze some trends in the united
states as we creep ever closer to techno
dystopia
there's a trend in modern entertainment
we used to see a lot of optimistic
movies and tv shows where the future was
depicted as bright happy and peaceful
there were exceptions of course but the
general feeling towards the far future
was one of hope
these days that's no longer the case
scroll through any list of movies and tv
and you'll notice a pattern just about
every bit of media dealing with the
future now has a decidedly pessimistic
tone the hunger games the maze runner
divergent oblivion altered carbon snow
piercer the expanse even kid-friendly
movies like wall-e have a deeply
dystopian undertone what's behind this
trend well if you take a look around it
shouldn't be hard to find the catalyst
people today are more unsure about the
future than at perhaps any point in
modern history every day we wake up and
there's a new catastrophe massive
wildfires record-breaking heat waves
disappearing glaciers melting permafrost
political instability new diseases
people are afraid and one way we like to
cope with our fear and uncertainty is by
turning off and watching a movie
dystopian fiction is increasingly common
these days for a couple of reasons first
it's weirdly comforting we can watch
snow piercer and say well at least my
life isn't that bad another reason is
that film and television offer us a way
to engage with modern problems in a way
that feels less traumatic we can watch
altered carbon recognize the problems
that mirror those in our own time and
come away thinking yeah rapidly
increasing inequality is a problem we
need to address it's a more pleasant
experience than watching a documentary
about collapsing ecosystems and runaway
climate change but it brings those same
issues to mind people like to relate to
what they're watching even if the
subject matter is unpleasant in a way
dystopian fiction performs a useful
service in this regard people who would
otherwise ignore the news and the
challenges we face are forced to see the
similarities between these fictional
worlds and the one we inhabit but simply
recognizing the problems doesn't do much
except make the average person miserable
we often feel powerless in the face of
monstrous crises like climate change and
inequality that exceeds that of the
gilded age but we're not as helpless as
we might feel we'll get to that a bit
later but first we need to take a look
at where the u.s stands on the dystopia
timeline okay picture a generic near
future dystopia what do you see grimy
cities pollution crushing poverty
juxtaposed against glistening neon
towers and usually a handful of massive
all-powerful corporations running the
show
that description may already be ringing
alarm bells in your head but let's break
it down a bit
good dystopian fiction usually relies on
a handful of tropes some kind of
environmental collapse
absurd levels of wealth inequality and
powerful technocrats ruining lives and
often the planet to fund their empire
and their megalomania let's evaluate the
united states based on these three
factors we'll start with environmental
issues unless you've been living under a
rock you know by now that climate change
is happening and it's not looking good
the fallout from the rapid warming
caused mainly by human activity will be
severe and it's already begun as of
writing this script greece has been
burning for over a week and is showing
no signs of stopping
thousands of people have had to evacuate
under red skies blistering heat and
suffocating smoke other countries face
similar conditions as we saw in
australia not too long ago coastal
regions face unprecedented flooding as i
saw firsthand while shooting a
documentary in the marshall islands
we're beginning to see the first climate
refugees as entire regions become
uninhabitable the ipcc an international
group at the forefront of climate
research has just put out their most
recent paper and it's shocking you may
be thinking yeah yeah i've heard this
before it's true the entire scientific
community has been begging policymakers
to listen for decades but guess what
it's looking like it's too late
the new report is full of data that even
the experts didn't expect at least not
so soon glaciers are melting at rates
that should be happening at higher
levels of warming
permafrost is melting at rates climate
scientists didn't expect we'd see for
another 70 years flooding exceeds
expectations as do droughts wildfires
and extreme weather the bottom line is
that 1.5 degrees of warming which has
been the number scientists have urged us
to try to stay below is going to produce
consequences that look more like three
degrees of warming the climate crisis is
accelerating we can no longer ignore the
fallout it's only going to get worse
now it's only dystopian if we refuse to
adapt and mitigate the fallout right
surely world leaders are working
tirelessly to solve the problem come on
you should know better than that
without fail world leaders are refusing
to take sufficiently radical steps to
stave off the worst effects of climate
change in fact here in the us the
current administration is carrying on
with business as usual
while republicans will openly deny
climate change to muddy the waters and
keep their corporate donors happy plenty
of well-meaning americans believe the
democrats actually care
they do not
while they pay lip service to
long-establish science the democrats are
beholden to the same corporate interests
as their more repugnant colleagues for
example biden recently said we can't
wait to tackle the climate crisis the
signs are unmistakable the science is
undeniable and the cost of inaction
keeps mounting that's nice and yet
approvals for oil drilling are on track
to reach their highest level since
george w bush was president a
politician's words don't mean anything
if they constantly act in a way that
contradicts their flowery language
the situation is pretty grim politicians
understand this but they are invested
often literally in the preservation of
the status quo which benefits them and
the rest of the rich and powerful read
the ipcc report for yourself i've left a
link in the description voting for the
less awful presidential candidate isn't
enough anymore
while climate change is definitely the
most pressing issue facing our species
and many other species dystopian fiction
often focuses on smaller scale
human-centric problems one of the most
quintessential of these is the issue of
rampant inequality the wealthy looking
down on the unwashed masses from their
glittering towers
in altered carbon the rich have found a
way to essentially become immortal the
final hurdle for the elite while the
poor are left to suffer and die far
below the cloud top utopias of society's
upper crust the quest for immortality is
something that our own billionaires are
absolutely pursuing there's one startup
which offers plasma transfusions from
the blood of young people in an effort
to slow the aging process
some of the more dedicated elite like
paypal founder peter thiel routinely
spend 40 000 per quarter for blood
transfusions from 18 year olds we also
have the absurdly wealthy going on
little joy rides to space just because
they feel like it jeff bezos spent 5.5
billion dollars to spend 11 minutes as
far above the poor people as he could
possibly get meanwhile his workers who
do the actual labor that produces
amazon's profits face some of the most
inhumane conditions in the country to
get a sense of just how absurdly rich
these people are consider this
there was one open seat on the flight
the person who had the winning bid
nearly 28 million dollars cancelled
because of a scheduling conflict
can you imagine that sorry can't make it
to my 28 million dollar space flight
something came up bezos has long been
the subject of intense criticism from
the left but he's really done it now
even older more conservative people saw
this little stunt as an obscene waste of
money in a way i'm glad it happened it
is nearly impossible for people to
understand just how much money our
modern day robber barons have hoarded
watching jeff bezos blow 5.5 billion
dollars on an 11-minute joyride helps
put it in perspective
that 5.5 billion doesn't even put a dent
in his wealth while it's easy to point
at the richest handful of people on
earth and say bad there is still
tremendous inequality several rungs
below them for example jamel brown a
hospital janitor in missouri was awarded
employee of the month after contracting
kovid trying to keep other people safe
for his efforts he was given a six
dollar voucher to the hospital cafeteria
meanwhile the ceo who has likely never
set foot on the premises got a 13 raise
to 30 and a half million dollars
this executive receives 1 000 times the
compensation of workers society called
essential for six months and then cast
aside jemele brown once considered an
essential worker can't afford his own
apartment and hasn't gotten a raise in
two years
absurd offensive stories like these
really help to drive the point home for
average americans our lives continue to
get worse while the already rich
continue to get richer here's another
example larry fink the ceo of blackrock
the world's largest asset manager went
on the record to say that americans will
have to work longer and make risky
investments in order to retire people
like fink are the same ones who say the
economy is doing great and anyone who
works hard can succeed yet here he is
with a tacit admission that people can't
get by on the same number of years of
work as their parents or grandparents
people in today's job market simply
aren't paid enough money to save for
retirement but if you want to get really
dystopian let's take a look at how the
state treats its least fortunate this
video was taken in venice beach here you
can see a few people in a makeshift
shelter not bothering anyone with
nowhere else to go being forcibly
evicted by police armed with assault
rifles as the country faces a wave of
evictions unlike anything we've ever
seen remember this video this is how the
homeless are treated over 30 million
americans are facing homelessness
because their savings were destroyed by
the pandemic 30 million inequality in
the united states now exceeds even that
of the gilded age the most extreme
disparity in the country's history with
every crisis the rich get richer those
who consider themselves middle class
lose everything and the poor fall deeper
and deeper into crushing poverty the
final trope in our dystopia comparison
is the ever-present hand of the
technocrats and the giant corporations i
think it should go without saying that
this country is run by corporations in
all but name why haven't we acted on
climate change because exxon has lobbied
against it for decades despite being
among the first ones to realize their
activity would cause problems down the
line
they fund both parties so does the
military-industrial complex companies
like lockheed boeing and raytheon why do
you think we're always involved in
low-level wars it's absurdly profitable
for these companies why don't we have
universal healthcare like every other
industrialized nation because the
insurance and pharmaceutical companies
make massive donations to both
republicans and democrats then you've
got the mega corporations like amazon
google and disney want to buy something
amazon has it cheaper streaming video
amazon has it delivery amazon groceries
amazon space flight apparently if you
have 28 million dollars
disney is slowly consuming all other
media companies and ips google dominates
web traffic this country is run by
corporations and they want to make sure
it stays that way but let's talk about
the really dystopian stuff there's a
nevada bill up for consideration that
would allow tech companies to create
their own cities complete with
governments the right to develop their
own taxation and essentially equal power
to traditional counties that's exactly
as terrifying as it sounds your job
would have complete control over your
life determining what you can and can't
do how little they're allowed to pay you
how much you owe them in taxes we have
this weird fixation on the private
sector especially tech in the u.s and
it's going to get us into real trouble
so-called industry leaders like bill
gates also enjoy essentially limitless
positive press for even their most
alarming projects for example gates
wants to shoot dust into the atmosphere
to block the sun if that sounds familiar
well it just so happens to be the
catalyst for one of our dystopian movies
then there's every internet dweeb's
favorite oligarch elon musk
neuralink the company determined to put
a computer chip in your brain will be
starting human trials in the very near
future and musk has just announced that
spacex will launch a satellite into
space with the purpose of displaying
advertisements any interested parties
will be able to buy ad space with crypto
soon even the night sky will not offer
an escape from the intrusion of capital
so is the us becoming a dystopia our
climate is collapsing inequality is at
its worst level ever our politicians are
corrupt and in the pocket of massive
corporations millions of americans are
on the brink of eviction at which point
they will be threatened with state
violence tax startups may soon have
their own autonomous cities where they
will have complete control over the
inhabitants we've got space billboards
on the way and people are lining up to
get microchipped by the world's least
responsible twitter troll i don't think
it's a stretch to say that the us is not
becoming a dystopia it already is one we
just don't have the flying cars or
cyberpunk aesthetics so what can average
people do about this i'm not going to
lie we face some serious problems
including the biggest one humanity has
ever faced but we're never powerless the
best thing you can possibly do is get
involved somewhere every little bit
helps want to organize your workplace
for better conditions join the iww or
another union applicable to your field
want to build political power join an
organizing group or a socialist party
start small see if there's something you
can do to help your neighbors look
around to see if you can find a local
mutual aid effort building community
resilience is critical to weathering
crises a group of people working
together is much stronger than a bunch
of isolated strangers if you like to
read start a reading group introduce
people to anti-capitalist ideas and help
them learn about alternatives if you're
good at graphic design see if your local
union socialist party branch or dsa
chapter needs help producing posters or
flyers there's always something we can
do to lend a hand it may not seem like
much to you but by working together we
can make a big difference take care of
yourself help others where you can and
throw sand in the gears of the machine
if our elected representatives and their
corporate overlords continue to make our
lives worse at every turn if they aren't
going to fix these massive problems that
they've created we need to do it
ourselves
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon when i
decided to make the shift from general
interest stuff to more radical political
content i knew i ran the risk of syncing
my channel and losing my ad revenue and
sponsors these days it's pretty hard to
get a sponsor on my videos i have one
reliable one and they're great but for
the most part i'm having to rely on the
generous support of viewers like you if
you appreciate the work i'm doing and
you're able to chip in even a dollar a
month i would greatly appreciate the
support as a little show of that
appreciation every patron regardless of
donation amount gets early access to
every video as well as access to our
patrons only discord server it's a great
place to hang out chat with other
like-minded people or learn about
socialist theory in our book club i'm
also pretty active in the server so
you're always welcome to ping me to ask
a question or just say hi you can find
my patreon join our growing discord
server and get early access to every
video at patreon.com second thought if
you enjoyed this video consider dropping
a like if you hated it a thumbs down you
can check out my previous videos by
clicking the links on your screen thanks
for watching and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you